very good numbers economically the
country is doing really well we expect
great things and we have a lot of
potential a lot of way to go with the
hottest economy now definitely actually
for the last quite a quite a bit period
of time and I think we have tremendous
potential for a lot of growth Europe is
not doing well a lot of places are not
doing very well we're doing very well so
I just want to let you know
well as you know we have a very close
alliance with the UK and we always have
we heard that the United States has very
few tankers going in because we're using
our own energy now we've made a lot of
progress over the last two and a half
years so we don't have very many tankers
going in but we have a lot of ships
there that are warships and we'll talk
to the UK and we have no written
agreement but we have an agreement
they've been a very great ally of ours
so we heard about it we heard it was one
we heard it was two and we'll be working
with the UK they'll have a new prime
minister soon which is a good thing and
we'll be working with the UK but we have
no written agreement but I think we have
an agreement which is long-standing
if you go back into the four
Congresswomen the things they've said
about our country are terrible what
they've said about Israel are just
terrible I don't know I can't say for
sure but certainly a lot of people say
they hate our country and I think it's a
disgrace what they've said I think you
can't talk that way about the United
States and I think frankly to say that
about Israel you know we just gave the
embassy in Jerusalem making Jerusalem
the capital of Israel I just gave Golan
Heights recognized Golan Heights for
Israel I've done all of this for Israel
and then you have these people I think
that Omar I find it hard to believe but
I hear Omar today put in or yesterday
put in a sanctions bill against Israel
and other things beyond sanctions so
when I hear that you just can't talk
about our country that way and when
people are angry at them I fully
understand it
I don't know if it's good or bad
politically I don't care but when people
are speaking so badly when they call our
country garbage think of that that's
worse than the plural well they call our
country garbage I don't care about
politics I don't care if it's good or
bad about politics many people say it's
good I don't know if it's good or bad I
can tell you this you can't talk that
way about our country not when I'm the
president so I think they've said
horrible things they're anti-semitic and
you look at the kind of statements they
made about Israel it's a disgrace to say
what they want about our country that's
what the Constitution guarantees do you
see not agreeing with you as the same
thing as hating the country yeah they
have First Amendment rights but that
doesn't mean I'm happy about them saying
and when they say bad things about us we
can certainly feel and again we have
First Amendment rights also we can
certainly feel what and say what we want
if you're right a statement jst
so we're going to be speaking with the
UK and this only goes to show what I'm
saying about Iran truffle nothing but
trouble and remember this the agreement
the ridiculous agreement made by
President Obama expires in a very short
period of time it was a short-term
agreement when you're dealing in
countries you have to deal in 50 years
in a hundred years you don't deal in the
short term that was a ridiculous
agreement and it goes to show you I was
right about Iran and let's see what
happens but I know that it's not
American ship its UK I guess it could be
one could be too and we'll be speaking
to them they have a new prime minister
coming soon and that's a good thing for
the UK believe all people are great
people I believe everyone is great but I
love our country and I'm representing
our country and people can't go around
speaking about our country and saying
garbage this is the greatest country in
the world we now have the strongest
military by far we had a depleted
military when I took over we spent seven
hundred and sixteen billion dollars last
year seven hundred billion dollars a
year before we have a great powerful
military more powerful than we've ever
had before we have the greatest economy
on earth not even close you can't speak
about our country the way those four
congressmen they said garbage they say
things about Israel that's so bad I'm
not even going to repeat them right now
they can't get away with that act not
the right
these women have said horrible things
about our country and the people of our
country nobody should be able to do that
and if they want to do that that's up to
them
but I can't imagine they're going to do
very well at the polls and I say this if
the Democrats want to embrace people
that hate our country people that are
far so far left that nobody has ever
seen it anything like it if they want to
embrace people that are so anti-semitic
and anti-israel they want to do that
that's up to them but I don't have to do
that I think what they say and what
they've said is a disgrace to them to
the Democrats and frankly to our country
a long time ago yeah 15 years ago I had
a fall again well I didn't get along
with them
I don't really know I'd have to look
into it that's a long time ago I do
think we have bigger problems than
plastic straws you know it's interesting
about plastics rugs so you have a little
straw but what about the plates the
wrappers and everything else that a much
bigger and they're made of the same
material so the straws are interesting
everybody focuses on the straws there's
a lot of other things to focus in but
it's an interest it's an interesting
question go ahead talk up so secretary
minuchin did have a call with the
Chinese counterpart they had a very good
talk we'll see what happens we're
dealing with China and we're doing very
well they are not doing very well they
has the worst year they've had in 27
years and we're having the best year we
ever had so we're doing well but let's
see what happens and our farmers are
doing very well because I've taken some
of the billions of dollars of tariffs
that we collect from China we collect
billions and billions of dollars of fees
and tariffs and I gave it to our farmers
false information who is fake news
enough I talk about it but they didn't
advise me they told me but I didn't it's
fake and judging by the way what you're
saying fake goose
[Music]
well Rand is a friend of mine but I have
really 53 very good friends and they're
in the Senate I also have a lot of
friends you saw that the other day when
they brought a ridiculous vote up and
only four Republicans out of hundreds
voted against so I have a lot of great
friends I'm ninety four percent in the
Republican Party approval rating Rand is
a friend of mine and Rand asked maybe
could get involved the answer is yes and
if other senators asked me to get
involved I'd probably say yes depending
on who they were we'll see what happens
but I have many people involved and Iran
is going to work out very nicely a Rand
is showing their colors going to work
out very nicely Iran is in big trouble
right now their economy is crashing it's
coming to a crash they're trying to
bring soldiers back home because they
can't pay them a lot of bad things are
happening to them and it's very easy to
straighten out or it's very easy for us
to make it a lot worse
say it
now you know what's racist to me when
somebody goes out and says the horrible
things about our country the people of
our country that are anti-semitic that
hate everybody that speak with scorn and
hate that to me is really a very
dangerous thing
I think these four congressmen and I
could say some worse than others but if
you look at the snape as they've made
what they call the people of our country
in our country garbage when they hit
Israel the way they've hit Israel so
hard so horrible I think to me that's a
disgrace and we should never forget it
we're dealing with people that hate our
country no I know I know let me tell you
they had an impeachment vote the other
day just a big waste of time it's a
disgrace no other president should ever
have to go through it and the vote was a
totally lopsided vote with many
Democrats voting in favor as far as I'm
concerned they already took their
impeachment vote and the impeachment
vote was so lopsided it was a met it was
a massive victory and you know what at
some point they have to stop playing
games because they're just playing games
no I won't be watching ball
[Music]
[Music]
we're looking at JimBob Way right now
[Music]
the first lady feels very strongly about
our country the first lady thinks that
it's horrible what they've said about
Israel and horrible what they've said
about our country these Congress women
they can't call our country in our
people garbage they can't be
anti-semitic they can't talk about evil
Jews which is what they say evil Jews
that's what the first lady
[Music]
[Music]